what is up I watched my first episode of
scrubs and it was a little mean-spirited
for me but you guys have been telling me
non-stop in the comments that I'm gonna
love the show I scoured the internet and
found out that Brendan Fraser is on
episode 22 of season one wrestled in
college I remember one of my favorite
movies as a kid and don't ask me why
because it's not a great movie was with
him and Elizabeth Hurley called
bedazzled where she plays the devil and
he gets wishes and he gets to do all
types of stuff I loved his humor I also
found Elizabeth Hurley very attractive
oh my god that's disgusting I did dose
him with morphine and the x-ray says the
nail went straight through so it's not
that big a deal oh dear god she's
getting woozy quickly show her the
bloody side yeah oh it's nail I'm gonna
touch it touch the nail touch my nail
it's so mean but it's true some people
do have what we call a vasovagal
reaction when they see blood their blood
pressure drops they faint temporarily
this is not a deadly condition but the
sight of blood it's scary it stimulates
the part of your nervous system that
makes you fear for your life and to some
people if it gets over activated you can
faint like that when I was a medical
student I was doing a lot of ABG's which
is an arterial blood gas you have to put
the needle right into the radial artery
unlike veins you can't see the arteries
you have to feel them which makes the
procedure that much more difficult but
it's a high pressure system so when you
put the needle in if you miss or the
needle tip is not inserted properly
blood can start squirting out one of my
first few times doing that I put the
needle in blood started squirting out
the patient fainted luckily they were
laying in their bed but they were so
worried that they saw the side of their
own blood that they passed out let's get
you to a hand surgeon so the reason why
the ER doctor or the internal medicine
doctor doesn't handle this complicated
case of the nail going through the hand
is because the hand is really
complicated that's why you need such a
subspecialist you don't just need a
surgeon now just a plastic surgeon you
need a hand surgeon the hand has
ligaments bones nerves blood vessels and
they're all in such close proximity if
you don't know the anatomy inside and
out and how it reacts to a nail going
through it you're gonna have a tough
time there's gonna be a higher rate of
complications wait wait wait stop stop
I'm guessing mr. Weinberg is Jewish yeah
so why isn't he circumcised a recent
medical study found that a mistake is
made on about 20% of all patients most
of these are clerical and harmless but
it still adds up to a lot of near misses
dr. wen wants me to ask you if there
could be a mix-up because our pen decide
is patient that dude doesn't have an
appendix hospitals make mistakes
patients unfortunately get ill as a
result of a hospital complication when
you go to a hospital if you notice that
the doctors are trying to eagerly get
you out and expedited as fast as
possible to go home the reason is not
because we want you out but it's because
we want to lower the chances of you
having a hospital complication you're
pregnant what now my fiance and I
decided not to have sex until we were
married so he's not gonna be so happy
can't stop thinking about mr. Weinberg's
testicles dude I mean I almost removed
one of them Todd which one like it
matters oh it matters fun fact about
testicles one of the testicles usually
hangs lower than the other some men get
worried about that and actually come see
me to make sure everything's okay but
that is a normal variant you're not
pregnant the lab check just switched the
samples you're killing me
hey sweetie you know I was just joking
about all that stuff right Jesus
samples can get switched up this doesn't
regularly happen but we talked about
this on the past episode of scrubs that
when hospitals are more ready to admit
their mistakes and point out what they
did wrong apologize tell the patients
what the plan is gonna be so they don't
repeat the mistake there's less likely
to get sued it's always important to
keep in mind even though that's just a
totally hilarious seat it turns out she
wasn't really pregnant after all some
idiot mislabeled her urine sample I was
a heartbeat away from giving appendix
patient a cross lobotomy if I do my best
and I lose a patient you know what I can
with that but if a clerical error is the
reason why guys walking around here with
only the lonely dam that don't sit well
with the big dog well that's why
nowadays we do a timeout where we
literally before we start the operation
before the patient gets put under we say
the patient's name we describe the
procedure we talk about the site of the
surgery we get the nurse to confirm the
doctor to confirm so everybody's on the
same page which decreases the likelihood
of making a mistake oh and very
important to note while the patient's is
sleeping we're performing the surgery
the nurse that's in charge of assisting
the doctor is counting all of the
instruments is accounting
how many gauze pads are being used all
of the rags everything is counted before
and after to make sure nothing gets left
inside the patient because this has
happened before
and it's a horrible horrible mistake I
was paged because Ben's blood work was
finally ready
unfortunately the chart wasn't in the
outbox I'd knock but the
hematopathologist is the meanest intern
hating his monster in this hospital it's
funny because nowadays all our results
are in the computer so as soon as we get
results back we just pop open a computer
all the results are there to review we
have any questions we can contact a
pathologist or radiologist whoever's
running the tests to get more info but
computers have made this process a lot
easier come on good news hey Bambi
couldn't can't quite catch that are you
okay leukemia leukemia is a form of
blood cancer it's been known to be a
children's cancer we just slightly
incorrect cuz more adults get it
essentially what you have is an increase
in white blood cells and this is an
improper increase and it's such a big
increase that it pushes out the red
blood cells even the platelets platelets
are the cells that clot so if you have a
cut they're the ones that come in and
fill that clot so for example here
he has such a spike in his white blood
cells that he's actually pushing out the
platelets and he's unable to clot
properly that's why he's bleeding while
shaving he's bleeding out of his wound
too much and also something very
commonly that happens when patients tell
me is when they brush their teeth
there's an excessive amount of blood and
it stays around for a while Janis are
those the test results we've been
waiting for wait a sec first Turks
patient
Eliot's this is a mistake I just I feel
it in my gut
I'm sure of it hello Janice uh no this
is something no that lab is backed up
again and so I'm a nice you know a
little while actually he's not wrong in
doing that when I have a patient who I
guess it's not the same as this
situation but let's say I have a patient
who doesn't have any symptoms and I
order blood tests for a screening
purpose and something comes out horribly
and inaccurate signaling a form of
disease my first job is to recheck that
lab value to make sure that there wasn't
a mistake
because that does happen there's been
times where I checked the red blood cell
count of my patients and found them to
be horribly anemic it didn't make sense
it didn't fit their clinical symptoms it
didn't fit their vital signs so I asked
the lab to repeat the test and voila
their labs were totally normal so if you
feel that the clinical presentation
doesn't match what's on the blood
recheck it you know there's only one
more person to talk to
the hematopathologist
hello homie dr. Bob you go by your first
name no first names Fred Fred Bob what
can I do you for better around check
Bend Sullivan's blood smear well that
depends on man do you actually think I
made a mistake or do you just wish I did
I kind of wish you did then I'll do it
sorry there died 70 security guard guy
cold out here huh yes where is his wound
he just had a nail go through his right
hand sweetie
[Music]
being a lab nerd that was a mistake
whenever you put a slide onto a
microscope you have to use the lowest
magnification possible so that you don't
put the high magnification on and then
end the break in the slide let's try
this again are those the test results uh
yeah
when you have leukemia
[Music]
this sucks
yeah as much as they try to make light
of the situation I think the way that he
deliver that news is actually ideal when
you're straightforward and honest and
quick to the point that's the best way
of delivering bad news you have to
understand what a patient is going
through you have to give them time to
process it if you feel that they need
some more information or reassurance you
can give that to them but I like to hold
out and ask them what questions they
have and understand that when you're
delivering bad news a lot of it is not
going to stick especially the dense
information like about treatment options
this that you have to let the patient
process it just give them a little piece
of information and then just be there
for them they can scream they can yell
they can be quiet everyone has different
reactions depending on their personality
and it's not an easy situation
there's also hits home for me because
unfortunately I lost my mom while in
medical school to leukemia a form of
leukemia known as CLL delivering this
type of news is something I have to do
often it's a tough situation all around
but if you can be straightforward you
could be honest and really care and even
cry that's okay a lot of doctors think
you have to be unemotional and not cry
if you feel that to cry cry you're a
human that's okay
scrubs is truly starting to grow on me
so please keep recommending the episodes
and click on this playlist that I
created of my favorite medical drama
reviews stay happy and healthy